good morning believe nations today's
message is put out positive energy over
to you demi lovato
[Music]
I'm a firm believer in what you put out
in the universe comes back to you you
know so you know even if it's as crazy
as I have this dream car that I want or
maybe it's not materialistic maybe it's
like I just want perfect health and I
want to fall in love and I want this and
not my family you know if you put it out
there it will come back to you in return
and I think it's just whether you it's
the universe God like whatever you
believe in I think that if you put that
energy out there it definitely comes
back and it's pretty crazy I had a night
where I was just like frustrated and I
was like you know I've been working hard
it's been about six months or whatever
since skyscraper came out or maybe even
like eight months and I was just like
I'm so frustrated like I'm not where I
want to be and I just released give your
heart a break and I just remember just I
was like you know what God like this is
all for you
like I'm just I'm going to do it I'm
going to work hard blah blah blah ten
days later I literally got the phone
call from Simon Cowell asking if I
wanted to be a judge having positive
energy makes all the difference in the
world if you have ever felt a burst of
energy that came to you after having a
meeting with somebody or delivering a
public speech or talking to a customer
or reading a book or watching a video
and you felt that hi you felt this so
great I want to go and do it again then
you know what I'm talking about you know
how value a positive energy is and how
much of a force it can be in your life
to go out and create amazing things I
think to be an entrepreneur you have to
be a force for good you have to be at
the core somewhat optimistic and then
you can make great things happen because
the odds are overwhelmingly against you
most businesses will fail and won't work
out and so you have to believe that it
will for you to keep going when
everybody says that you're crazy if you
have ever felt that feeling of the
boldness and the high and the creativity
and the
to do something amazing and felt I'm
going to capture that how can i bottle
that how do I make that so that I can
drink that every single day when you
find out what works for you I think it's
critical to put that as part of your
daily routine ideally in the morning
we've talked about the one channel it's
super important whether it's meeting
people up here if you're an extrovert
you like to meet people you have to get
out of the house to get out of bed get
out of the office and go have a coffee
with somebody then start that make that
the first thing you do every day if you
need to watch videos of famous
entrepreneurs and see people being
successful and dream of I want to be
successful too then start your day with
that as well understand that that's what
helps you reach a higher level so plan
it in don't have it happen to you
randomly I think too many people just
happen to consume the right content at
the right time and it helps them but
then you fall back off your path and you
don't remain consistent and you go back
down to where you were before so if you
love a certain YouTube channel that gets
you inspired and pumped up then watch
every morning a piece of that YouTube
channel whether it's mine or somebody
else's or maybe it's reading a book or
maybe it's having a conversation if
talking to your mom gets you fired up
amped up self-confident thinking bold
then do that talk to your mom every
morning I think once you understand what
it is it gives you positive energy and
you can factor your schedule around it
you are much more likely not just to be
a happier person but to achieve a lot
more success and have a higher chance of
falling through and hitting your goals
the second part of it I would say is
once you understand how to do it
yourself then you can recognize and I
think it's also responsibility to do it
for others if you understand how
important having that external positive
vibe is for yourself to get you in the
position of being positive and upbeat
and optimistic every day then how can
you be that source that light that spark
for other people for your customers for
your suppliers for your community for
your family for your team the people
around you don't be the person who's
bringing everybody there is nobody wants
to hang out would be the person who
builds people up who helps them have
confidence and courage and belief in
themselves if you have figured out how
to do it for yourself then you can be a
right for other people and I would say
it's your responsibility to do so don't
just hold on to the goodness yourself
share it make other people's lives
better it's part of why I do these
videos for you it helps me I love it but
I love knowing that it's helping other
people as well I love knowing that you
guys are some are you watching every
single day some of you start your day if
you start your day every day with a
video on my channel leave in the
comments I want to see it because I get
messages from you guys that get snaps
and getting emails from a lot of you
seen you start your day every day with
one of my videos that makes me feel
great you can feel like the work I'm
doing is important having an impact I
want to share the positive energy and
then you guys are going to in it and
you're dishing it out to your community
you're dishing that into your product
you're dishing out to your customers and
to your family and the people around you
and so step one is figuring out what
gives you the positive energy and how
can you make that consistent and part of
your daily routine and - once you figure
that out it's your responsibility to go
and share with others and be alike in
other people's day as well so the
question they today is how many of you
start your day with one of my videos
what's your frequency once a day
multiple times a day once a week once a
month never accept this video loser down
the comments below I'm really curious
define it I also want to give a quick
shout out to Shawna Fitzpatrick China
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book here one word it really means
so much to me and I really hope that you
are enjoying the book thank you for your
support thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events better
so give me go
I have to show up at work with the right
attitude and with the positive energies
and I actually had a t-shirt made the
positive energy is a part of your job
description right so the idea that I
want to show up with the right energy I
want to show up you know we're all here
you know even now we're all here we're
trying to feed our families where we're
dry have a good time we're talking about
there this is an important part of our
lives our time is all that we had so to
me is hugely important to deliver
positive energy in a way because it
sorry
so I come to fathers of energy and
someone else is going to take out all
the positive energy and irritate me home
to your families and you know Tony is
just hugely important to approach
everything and everybody at every turn
with the being the most positive loving
kindness that I can generate my father
was a was in the construction so I used
to like help him out you know his father
building houses and stuff like that but
I didn't really start working until I
got out of jail for the first time when
I got out of jail for the first time I
did a year in jail for somebody we tend
to kill every night 30 years but my
father was trying to teach me a lesson
because I was such a bad kid so he was
trying to teach me a lesson so instead
of posting my bail he let me sit in jail
and I'm like ayano's 1617 is a tough
playing 97 96 97 so I didn't when I got
out of jail and I started saying yo in
order to change my life I got to change
my lifestyle so I didn't want to hustle
no more I never know big-time drug
dealer I was a quota spoon to know
corresponds when I'm from his 7 grams
he paid 250 for G flipped that you made
500 but when I went out the first jobs I
started working I remember I got a job
this way I was called IAC
dust real acoustics company I worked
there and I worked at on a flower garden
and I worked at Taco Bell I worked at
demo in the mall I worked at a
telemarketing place called Paragon
solutions and the reason I was doing all
that could always say
you got to create the kind of energy
that you want in your life if you
constantly keep creating positive energy
around you and more positive things will
come so I would be landing all these
jobs like I never was one that let my
rectly to stop me in my criminal record
and that's what eventually led me to get
an internship at directed stage because
I was just working I was working two and
three jobs at one time you know at one
point I worked at demo in the mall
Paragon solutions and telemarketing
agency and and interned at the radio
station it's like a psychic telling you
yo you won't be rich one day so you just
sit around and wait to be rich I don't
work like that you know when you're
constantly thinking about doing positive
things you got to actually go out there
you work towards those goals I thought I
told you earlier about just going out
and working at Taco Bell you know
working at a warehouse just trying to
create that positive energy of
production into my life I want to
highlight this that's something that you
can do in your own way tonight you can
validate others empower others increase
the net happiness the positivity in the
world I mean it could be as simple as
your family's going to have dinner
tonight and you go to a restaurant and
you see someone do something great and
too often we kind of just sit back - no
that was good that was good service
maybe you give an extra tip you're at
work or you see a colleague who goes
above and beyond and you say oh that was
pretty good they did a nice nice thing
and what I hope and this is something
that I tell myself all the time is don't
just sit by and observe it recognize it
when you see someone do something great
tell them about it tell their bosses
about it tell their family about it and
when you do that all sorts of neat
exciting things are going to start
percolating into the universe obviously
you're going to make that person today
you're going to make their year you
might make their career I've seen it
happen before you you probably in some
way will make their life even more
they're going to start doing that ultra
positive thing more that people around
them are going to see the recognition
they got for it and they're going to
start emulating it and even though that
wasn't your intent you just wanted to
highlight something good that's
happening in the world people will
recognize that you are our source of
positivity and when you're a source of
positivity people will just will just
naturally naturally gravitate to